ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE HE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
I AGREE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CERVANTES.
CHAO [inaudible]
JUNE [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
UBER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
LONG [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LEóN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
NINE MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA IN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAY IS LOOSE REBUS ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH.
STONE.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WORD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS SAY QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER
.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY PUSH TO REDUCE.
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. FIVE DAYS AGO MY
DEAR FRIEND CAROL CASTLE LOST
HER BRIEF ENCOUNTER WITH CANCER.
MY HUSBAND OFFICIATED HER
WEDDING THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO.
HER HUSBAND CAM KERO AND I WERE
ORDAINED TOGETHER YEARS AGO.
CAROL WAS MY CONFIDANTE IN I
ALWAYS FELT SPECIAL WHEN SHE OR
TEN WOULD SAY WE ARE FAMILY.
SHE WAS MADE TO LET GO OF LIFE.
ON THE TWENTY FOURTH BIRTHDAY OF
HER YOUNGEST DAUGHTER KIRI.
I LIKE TO READ WHAT KERRY SHARED
ON THAT UNFORGETTABLE DAY
[inaudible]
JULY THIRD.
A DAY TO NOT ONLY CELEBRATE MY
FIRST BREATH.
BUT ALSO TO CHERISH MY MOM'S
LAST.
I'M SO HONORED TO SHARE JULY
THIRD WITH MY MOM.
THROUGHOUT HER BATTLE WITH
CANCER SHE PROVED TO BE THE MOST
COURAGEOUS PERSON I'VE EVER
KNOWN.
HER GRACE DETERMINATION AND
STRENGTH DURING THE TRIALS SHE
FACED.
WILL ALWAYS BE IMPRINTED IN MAR
HEART AND MIND.
MOMMY I LOVE YOU MORE THAN ALL
THE STARS IN THE SKY.
THANK YOU FOR JULY THIRD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LOVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOU.
WE HAVE CRIED OFTEN TOGETHER
THROUGH THESE PAST DAYS.
I KNOW THE EACH PERSON HERE
KNOWS WELL.
THE DEATH OF A YOUNG KERRY'S
WORDS.
BUT AS WE SAID TO HER.
OUR TEARS OF SADNESS ARE ALSO
ARE TEARS OF LOVE.
HOW FORTUNATE YOU ARE TO HAVE
BEEN NURTURED BY SUCH LOVING
KINDNESS? FOR THAT SHE WILL BE
FOREVER GRATEFUL.
IN LIVING LIFE.
IT IS INEVITABLE THAT WE MUST
KNOW LOS.
BUT TO NO UNCONDITIONAL LOVE.
THIS MAY BE THE FULFILLMENT OF
OUR LIVES.
NUMBER AMUNDSEN WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER DALY.
PLEASE JOIN US OUR PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE CEMENT AT
SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE SO YOU AND
AGUIAR-CURRY SOME REMEMBER FOR
JUST A PRESIDING SYSTEM CHIEF
CLERK. TO PROGRAM THE DANCE
REPROGRAMMING AND WAS READING
FOLLOWING A PLACE ON THE MORNING
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
ISN'T PATIENTS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MELISSA MELENDEZ
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
ACT WE ARE CURRY AND FONG TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO A THE FONG NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. TO HOLD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY UPON
A GERMAN OF SESSION AND ROOM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN MR FLORA FOR
PURPOSES -- THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT ASK FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING.
YOUR CALDERON MOVES AND MR BONTA
SECONDS ON THE RULE SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I. THOUGH MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR
A NO.
VOTE TAKES FORTY ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION.
THIS CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I..
MR FLORA UNKNOWN. FOR ALL ON THE
MOTION.
TO SUSPEND THE RULES CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE ICE FORTY
FOUR NO.
SEVEN RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU GET
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE SB THREE NINETY
THREE STONE.
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE SB
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN LIKE OWSKI.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PLEASE RETURN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO THE SENATE.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NO
.
MEMBERS IF I COULD HAVE
ATTENTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE VERY SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT'S MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED
SPIRITUAL LEADERS THAT ARE HERE
FROM INDIA.
AND WITH US IN THE GALLERY THIS
AFTERNOON.
IS HOLINESS ACHARYA DR LOCATION
MOONEY IS A SOCIAL REFORMER
VERSATILE THINK A WRITER AND
POET. FOR THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
HE'S BEEN CONTINUOUSLY MAKING
EFFORTS FOR ESTABLISHING
COMMUNAL HARMONY NONVIOLENCE
PEACE MUTUAL COOPERATION IN
SOCIETY.
IN ORDER TO GIVE PROP SHAPE.
THESE VALUES HE FOUNDED A
HIMSELF VISUAL APART THE AND
DOES MADE HIS FIELD OF ACTIVITY
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
AND HE IS HERE AFTER SPENDING
THE WEEKEND AT THE JANA
CONVENTION IN ONTARIO A
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND FOLLOWERS OF THE GENE.
FACE.
UP ONE OF THE KEY NOTES AND SO
PLEASE WELCOME HIS HOLINESS
ATARI A DOCTOR LOCATION MOONEY
[inaudible]
IN.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE WITH US
GORE GOPAL DAS WHO WAS THE
KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT THE JANE
CONVENTION IN ONTARIO.
HE'S A FORMER HEWLETT PACKARD
ENGINEER TURNED INDIA LIFESTYLE
COACH MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKER WAS
PART OF THE INTERNATIONAL
SOCIETY FOR KRISHNA
CONSCIOUSNESS.
A STORYTELLER COACH AUTHOR A
FRIEND OF MILLIONS THAT PAUL HIS
JOURNEY ON SOCIAL MEDIA HIS
VIDEOS OF REACHED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION VIEWS.
AT ALL FOCUS ON ONE THING MAKING
UP MAKING A POSITIVE DIFFERENCE
IN THIS WORLD SO PLEASE WELCOME
MISTER GORE GOPAL THE US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
A MISTER BONTA YOU HAVE GUESSED
THAT HAVE JOINED US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE AND
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
THERE IN THE GALLERY.
FIFTEEN INCREDIBLE INTERNS FROM
MY CAPITAL ARE FROM MY DISTRICT
OFFICE WHO ARE HERE VISITING THE
CAPITAL -- TO EXPERIENCE WHAT WE
DO HERE EVERY DAY AND ALSO TO
SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS ON
LEGISLATION ON HOW BEST TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD THAT LET'S
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AND PLEASE BY THE WITH A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MS
BAUER QUE HAN FROM MRS
PETRIE-NORRIS IS DESTIN'S
BARRICADE HAND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TO WELCOME AT THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTEEN INTERNS WHO ARE
HERE WITH US IN THE GALLERY
TODAY.
THESE HARD WORKING YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE JOINED US ALL SUMMER TO
LEARN ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THIS IS DEATH THINKING
TO JOIN IN CONSTITUENTS OUTREACH.
AND MAKE OUR OFFICE FUNCTION
EVEN BETTER THAN IT DOES DURING
THE YEAR SO I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR ALL OF THEIR HELP FOR BEING
SO ENGAGED IN CALIFORNIA'S.
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND GIVE
THEM A WARM WELCOME TO OUR
CAPITAL THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
AND DOCTOR QUIRK.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND THE
MEMBER FROM WINTERS.
IN CELEBRATING THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THE AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES -- GRAHAM IS A STATE
WIDE NETWORK OF UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA RESEARCHERS AND
EDUCATORS.
DEDICATED TO THE CREATION
DEVELOPMENT AND APPLICATION OF
KNOWLEDGE.
IN AGRICULTURAL NATURAL AND
HUMAN RESOURCES.
THAT HOUSES THE UC INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THE INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM PARTNERS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AND IS ACTIVE IN URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS SCHOOLS.
AND CHILDCARE CENTERS THE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM PROVIDES.
A SCIENTIFICALLY TESTED PEST
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
INCREASE FOOD SAFETY ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS.
INCREASED PROFITABILITY FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
REDUCE PESTICIDE EXPOSURE.
IN MY DISTRICT THE PROGRAM'S
RESEARCH METHODOLOGY.
HAS LOWERED BED BUG INCIDENTS IN
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING.
BY 80%.
THE UC INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THE MáS IS WHAT YOU SEE
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES ALL ABOUT TODAY.
GETTING PRACTICAL INFORMATION
INTO THE HANDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SERVING AS A
TRUSTED.
PUBLIC RESOURCE FOR SCIENCE
BASED INFORMATION.
IN THE GALLERY.
FROM UC DAVIS WE HAVE JIM FARRAR
DIRECTOR UC STATEWIDE INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
MARK BELLES VICE PROVOST FOR
STRATEGIC INITIATIVES IN
STATEWIDE PROGRAMS FOR YOU SEE
OUR CULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
MARK LOOK RIMINI VICE PRO BASS
FOR PROVOST FOR RESEARCH AND
EXTENSION.
UC AGRICULTURAL NATURAL
RESOURCES AGAIN PLEASE JOIN US.
ACTUALLY THE NEW C. INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
ON THE FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY AND
COMMANDING THEM FOR THEIR
OUTSTANDING ACHIEVEMENTS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
OPERATE.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY THREE TO
EIGHTY FIVE THE MINUTES AND
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY WITHIN
MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS.
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR PASS
RETAIN WEIRD FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
MISTER SANTIAGO CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AN
ACCOLADE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
MISTER SANTIAGO I THINK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN SEVENTY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT
SUBJECTS LIKE ACCEPTING SMALL
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE THE
KNOT AYE SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE CAN CURTIN FILE ITEM SIX IS
A BEFORE SEVENTY THREE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY THREE
BY SOMEBODY REMAIN SHINING
ACCOLADES WAS STATES.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE IS -- A BEFORE SURGERIES
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
A RICH MAN CHANCY NOTICE KASHER
MADE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF BIZARRE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM SEVEN IS AB.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME WE WERE
REALLY MONNING ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC LANDS.
MS LAMONT EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY DE
COMMISSIONING TIMELINES.
AS A RESULT ALL OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN REMOVED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AMOUNT SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE BUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIE THAT ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM EIGHT IS AB FIVE NINETY ONE
CLERK READ.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AN ACCOLADE A MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICTS MS GARCIA YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
FOR CLARIFYING IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
FOR GLOBAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO CENTER MA'AM AND SIR
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM NINE FILE ITEM TEN IS AB
ONE THOUSAND CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THOUSAND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
INOCULATE A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION MR BUT TESS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER IN MEMORY MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS TAKING IN THE SENATE
OUR TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION BET ON THIS
ITEM.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE QUICK
READ.
SOME PEOPLE LIVE IN SEVENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CHILD CUSTODY.
THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO ADD CO
AUTHORS IN THE SENATE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES YOU TO
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO DEVELOP A
STANDARD FORM TO BE USED DURING
INVESTIGATIONS OF ALLEGED CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT IN CUSTODY
DISPUTES.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I WISH I
WAS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS PHONE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS
VETERANS ARE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THE BUT I SIXTY
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM TWELVE IS AB.
TWELVE THIRTEEN LOCAL RATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE THIRTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER CHEN AN ACCOLADE TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
DOCTOR CHECK EMAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWELVE
THIRTEEN IS BACK UP AND CURRENT
FROM THE SENATE.
AB FOURTEENERS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN IS AB.
TWELVE TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY ONE BY
pBACK LATER CHILD ABUSE.
MR COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT A. B. TWELVE TWENTY ONE
RELATED CHILD CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY CENTER FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL CREATES STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR WHAT SUCH A
CHILD ADVOCACY CENTER MOST OFFER
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
CLARA FIND.
OTHERS NO PPOSITION HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I REGION I
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN PAST
RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT COVERAGE.
SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON
ACTUALLY THE BUSINESS.
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS BACK.
ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
SIXTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TO COLLABORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER B<c.cyan> QUE HAN</c>
ACRYLATE FOOD FACILITIES MS PARA
QUE AND THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO WHICH
PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS FROM FOOD
DEADLY FOOD ALLERGENS IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE.
AND MEN INTO THE SENATE STRENGTH
IN THE BILL BY REQUIRING THAT
CROSS CONTAMINATION OF FOOD
ALLERGENS BE ADDED TO THE FOOD
HENLEY TRAINING CARD.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED NO
OPPOSITION BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IVAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A AYE.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO CENTER
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
SEVENTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT GREGORY.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AN
ACCOLADE TO INSURANCE DOCTOR
WEBER YES MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE THE CHANGES WERE
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES.
THIS BILL HAS -- NO NO VOTES AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION IS SPONSORED
BY THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CAR CLUB RURAL.
ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN IS AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
A HAZARDOUS WASTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK EMAIL.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
FIFTY NINETY SEVEN IS COMMITTEE
BILL REGARDNG THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
ELECTRONIC MANIFEST SYSTEM THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES TO MAKE
THE BILL CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL THE MANIFEST SYSTEM.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR CONCURRENCE
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
REYES OUT OF OUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TIRED BUT I SIXTY NINE OH ZERO
SEVEN MA'AM AND SIR CAN CURRENT
IN.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY HAS BEEN
RETURNED TO THE SENATE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE IS A C. R..
NINETY FIVE BY DR CHOI CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FIVE BY CELEBRATORY
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO SECURE LOW
DAY.
DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS
SIDE ACR NINETY FIVE VSL
RESOLUTION.
FOR SECURE YOUR LOW DAY OF THAT
IS ON CONCURRENT SUCH A SMALL
TECHNICAL.
AMENDMENT WAS MADE BY THE SENATE.
I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU THAT CHOICE IN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ADAMO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SAN MA'AM AND SIR
CAN CURTIN FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
IS H. A R. AIDS.
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO INVASIVE
SPECIES [inaudible]
DR COURT.
YES AJ ARE EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
WE'RE ASKING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR MONEY TO HELP US
ELIMINATE NUTRIA -- I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK WE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB WE'RE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE.
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY THREE AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
SIMPLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AN
ACCOLADE A DRINKING WATER.
MISTER CS.
THANK YOU AB SEVENTY SIX IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB CLUB THE ROLE.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS BETTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
ON RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX TO BE
CONTINUED.
ON THE ASSEMBLY IF THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY TO
PASS A RETAIN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE IS AJ ARE
TEN BY MS RADIUS CORKERY.
SOME JOINT RESOLUTION TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO V. VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION.
MS REST.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT AJ ARE
TEN A RESOLUTION WHICH MAKES AN
IMPORTANT STATEMENT REGARDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP.
EXPRESSING OUR DESIRE TO
MAINTAIN OUR AUTHORITY TO ENACT
STRICTER AIR POLLUTION STANDARDS
PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT.
WAIVERS OFFERED UNDER THIS ACT
WHICH HAVE BEEN ISSUED IN
SUPPORT OF ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS ALLOW
CALIFORNIA SOME STANDARD
CURRENTLY FOLLOWED.
BY OVER THIRTEEN STATES IN
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE US.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE NATIONAL
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC MINISTRATION AND
THE U. S. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY RECENTLY
PROPOSED.
UNDER THE PRESENT IN
ADMINISTRATION THE SO CALLED
SAFE VEHICLE RULE.
THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO TAKE
ACTION THAT WOULD WEAKEN THE
ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA TO ENACT
POLICIES THAT ADDRESS.
PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS EMBARKED ON
THE POORLY CRAFTED STRATEGY TO
ROLL BACK THE PROGRESS
CALIFORNIA'S MADE ON CLEAN AIR.
DESPITE THE SUPPOSEDLY BENEFITS
OF THE PROPOSAL THE CONSEQUENCES
OF ADOPTING THIS STANDARD WILL
BE DETRIMENTAL.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT TAKING THIS
ACTION WILL NOT ONLY INCREASE
OIL CONSUMPTION BY APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND BARRELS.
PER DAY BUT IT IS ESTIMATED TO
COST CALIFORNIA THIRTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS DUE TO NEGATIVE
EFFECTS ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA MUST CLEARLY STATE
THAT WE SUPPORT CLEAN AIR AND
THE NEED TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE AREA WHERE WE HAVE
THE MOST WORK TO DO.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
SUPPORT OF AJ OUR TOWN IS A VOTE
FOR SCIENCE FOR INNOVATION
CONSUMER CHOICE AND SUPPORT FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
OUR STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DAVIS REYES MR TING.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANT TO RISE AS WELL IN SUPPORT
OF HR -- TEN IF WE WANT CLEAN
AIR WE'RE GONNA NEED CLEAN CARS
AND A CLEAR STRATEGY TO MAKING
SURE WE HAVE CLEANER CARS ON THE
ROAD TODAY IS MAKING SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA.
MAINTAINS ITS PROGRESS IN
INSURING THEIR ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE TIED FUEL STANDARDS THERE
WERE ALSO ENCOURAGING EVERYBODY
TO MOVE TO CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE ON AJ ARE.
TO THANK YOU MISTER TEN SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION MS RACE WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS RACE IS REQUESTING THAT THE
FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A
CHAIR.
TEN THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION MEMBERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR FIFTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AJ ARE WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS.
ONE THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR MEMBERS ARE MOVING
IN THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
SENATE.
THREE FILE ITEMS THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX AND THIRTY SEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT IS SB.
FIVE FOUR FOR COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR BY
CENTER OF BERGEN ACCOLADE TO
ATTORNEYS.
MISS WICKS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE FOUR FOUR WHICH
PROHIBITS WHICH WILL PROHIBIT
THIS.
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR FROM ASKING
APPLICANTS TO SIGN A MEDICAL
WAIVER FOR MENTAL HEALTH HISTORY
VALUATION DURING THE APPLICATION
PROCESS TO BE ADMITTED TO
PRACTICE LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
IN CURRENT LAW THE STATE BAR HAS
UNCHECKED AUTHORITY TO REVIEW AN
APPLICANT'S MENTAL HEALTH
HISTORY WHICH IS AFFECTED WHEN
AND IF LAW STUDENTS SEEK MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT.
A SURVEY OF LAW STUDENTS HAS
FOUND THAT MANY EXPERIENCE
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY.
HOWEVER ONLY HALF OF THESE LAW
STUDENTS RECEIVED COUNSELING
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN OVER HOW
IT WOULD AFFECT THEIR BAR
ADMISSIONS ACT ACADEMIC
STANDINGS AND JOB PROSPECTS.
SB FIVE FOUR FOUR FOR IT
PROVIDES A CLARIFICATION THAT
THE STATE BAR WILL NOT DISCLOSE
AN APPLICANT'S MENTAL HEALTH
RECORDS.
AND ENSURES THAT MENTAL HEALTH
HISTORIES WILL NOT BE USED TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK LOCAL THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE IS SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
ABOUT THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE ACCOLADE ANIMAL
WELFARE.
DOCTOR EGGMAN EMAIL BUT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER A MEMBERS SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE BILL THAT
SIMPLY CONFORMS OUR LANGUAGE
WITH WHAT WE USE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT ANIMAL SHELTERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ADDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE HOWEVER I
SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY WE WILL TAKE A FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY ONE SB [inaudible]
THREE THREE NINE CARILLO.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR JONES ACCOLADE
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
MR LOW EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB THREE THIRTY NINE
WHICH ENHANCES CONSUMER
PROTECTION AMONGST LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS RESPECT
FAST RIVAL.
DAVIS LOVE SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND HOW
IT OUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS [inaudible]
424-034-0440.
FIVE AS WELL AS ITEMS FORTY SIX
THROUGH.
FIFTY WE WILL ALSO PASS AND
RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADD FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE S. J. R..
THREE MEMBERS WHEN A PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM
.
FIFTY ONE WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
PASS A RETAIN UP TO THROUGH.
FIFTY FIVE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER -- FIFTY SIX
THIS IS SB.
FIVE SIX EIGHT GREGORY.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY
CENTER PORTANTINO WHEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OPPOSE SECONDARY
EDUCATION
.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
AUTHORIZE GLENDALE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE'S GOVERNING BOARD
PURSUANT TO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING TO PROVIDE THAT
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH SHALL BE A
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOLIDAY.
KNOWN AS ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
REMEMBRANCE DAY.
A GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SERVES A CITY IN A REGION WITH
THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF
ARMENIANS OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA.
I'M WITHIN THE ARMENIAN DIAZ
BROKE GCC IS PROUD THAT OVER 35%
OF THE STUDENTS THEY SERVE IN
THEIR CREDIT PROGRAM AND 48% AND
THEIR NON CREDIT PROGRAM ARE OF
ARMENIAN ETHNICITY. FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS GCC HAS HAD COULD HOLD
COMMEMORATIONS AND EDUCATION
EVENTS.
DURING APRIL LEADING UP TO THE
ART THE APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE REMEMBRANCE
DAY.
TOPICS HAVE INCLUDED GENOCIDE IN
CONTEXT HISTORY AND POLITICS OF
THE DESTRUCTION AND DEPORTATION
OF THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE.
GENOCIDE DENIAL IT'S A FACT
ARMENIAN CULTURE AND ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IN LITERATURE.
HOWEVER ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
DUE TO STATE LAW G. C. C.'S
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TITLE FIVE
REGULATIONS.
GCC HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO DECLARE
PUBLIC HOLIDAY SO THAT ITS
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF COULD
JOIN WITH GLENDALE AND LA IS
REGIONAL COMMEMORATIVE EVENTS
AND MARCHES.
NOW THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
GLENDALE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
DOES HAVE THIS AS A HOLIDAY BUT
YOU SEE SEE IT'S BEEN ABLE TO DO
SO BECAUSE OF STATE LAW.
AND AT A TIME WHEN WE SEE HATE
CRIMES ARE RISING AND SEEING A
GREATER NEED FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND OUR CULTURES.
AND THE DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
THAT MAKE UP THE TAPESTRY OF LOS
ANGELES IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE PAUSE TO EDUCATE ALL OF
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN THE
REGION. TO SO THAT THEY WILL
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE THE
BACKGROUND AND THE TRAUMA THAT
IMPACTS SO MANY OF THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
I'M A WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST
FULLY -- HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU
CAN HELP ME ENJOY IT JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
THANK YOU VERY [inaudible]
FAMOUS FRIEDMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
IT IS OUT OF VOEPEL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AND
FIFTY NINE
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
SIXTY THIS IS SB [inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN COVERAGE.
SENATE BILL TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR REQUIRED OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS DECLARE OF
YOURS HERE UP SIGNIFICANTLY.
MR SANTIAGO.
I THINK EVER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
TODAY I'M ARE TO PRESENT SB
TWENTY SEVEN THE PRETTY SIMPLE
BILL IT'S CALLED THE
PRESIDENTIAL TRANSPARENCY ACT I
CAN'T ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
AND THIS JUST DOES A VERY SIMPLE
THING IT REQUIRES ANY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE -- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THE PRESENT HIS OR
HER -- TAX RETURNS FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
THIS HAS BEEN DONE FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS -- BY BOTH SIDES THE
AISLES BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE
INVOLUNTARILY.
SO WE SEEK THAT THE CAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REQUEST --
INCOME TAX RETURNS FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS FOR ANY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES ARE RUNNING IN THIS
STATE I BEFORE THEY COULD BE ON
THE BALLOT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK
MISTER MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR MEMBERS
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF MR
SANTIAGO WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE.
MR SANTIAGO MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE PAST RETAIN.
OF FILE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE THROUGH.
SIXTY EIGHT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM.
SIXTY NINE SB [inaudible]
FIVE OH FIVE KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH FIVE BY
SENATOR UMBERG ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS IN THE CLEAR THE UC
THEY'RE OFF THE CLICK
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKERSB FIVE
OH FIVE SEEKS TO CLARIFY THE
PROCESS FOR CANDIDATES TO GAIN
BALLOT ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
THE SECRETARY STATE CURRENTLY
HAS THE SOLE DISCRETION TO PLACE
RECOGNIZE CANDIDATES THROUGHOUT
THE NATION OR THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ON A POLITICAL
PARTY'S PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
BALLOT.
ANGEL CANDIDATES ARE NOT EVEN
REQUIRED TO FILL OUT FORMAL
PAPERWORK OR SUBMIT
DOCUMENTATION WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE TO APPEAR ON
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY BALLOT.
IN EXCLUDED CANDIDATE REGARDLESS
OF ELIGIBILITY OR DESIRE FOR THE
RESPECTIVE PARTY'S NOMINATION
COULD CHALLENGE THEIR EXCLUSION.
WHICH COULD RESULT IN
UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO THE STATE SB FIVE OH FIVE
WOULD CODIFY CERTAIN STANDARDS
AND REQUIRE THE SUBMISSION OF A
FORM TO THE SECRETARY STATE
ORDER FOR CANDIDATES TO SHOW A
BASIC LEVEL OF SUPPORT AND
SERIOUSNESS WHEN SEEKING THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND HAVE A CLEAR PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT OUT.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ.
SEEN KNOWN DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CAR CLUB OF THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AT A VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES
.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
SIXTY THAT IS SB TWENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
MR
SANTIAGO CALL
MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO AGAIN LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SB TWENTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY SIX NO SIXTEEN ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM GOING TO MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CAN'T.
ARMY.
MOVING TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND I
GUESS A CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE A ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO PEDIATRIC
CANCER RESEARCH.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT SENATE BILL
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO IN SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY
TWO I SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO MEMBERS IF YOU
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
UNDER MR TANG'S LEADERSHIP WILL
HAVE AN INFORMATION HEARING UPON
A GERMAN OF SESSION.
IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AS AN
INFORMATION HEARING.
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION.
IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JULY NINTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY JULY TENTH.
CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY JULY ELEVENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM
.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME
-- MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANT PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK FOR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN MEMORY
OF DONNA MARIE FULL YEAR THE
MOTHER OF MY DEAR FRIEND MARGE
WIFE THE FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROGER DICKINSON.
DONNA WAS A NATIVE OF ALAMEDA
HAVING BEEN BORN AND RAISED
THERE AND RETURN TO THE ISLAND
TO SPEND THE LAST FORTY YEARS OF
HER LIFE.
SHE PASSED AWAY QUIETLY IN JUNE
AFTER A SHORT ILLNESS.
DESCRIBED BY FRIENDS AS A ROLE
MODEL AND TRAIL BLAZER DONNA
WOULD DO ANYTHING FOR ANYONE AND
BUILT FRIENDSHIPS WHERE EVER SHE
WENT.
DONNA WAS AN EXCELLENT STUDENT
AT THE EIGHT AT AN EARLY AGE.
SHE GRADUATED FROM A MATH
ALAMEDA HIGH SCHOOL.
AT SIXTEEN YEARS OLD AND ENTERED
YOU SEE BERKELEY WHERE SHE
EARNED HER B. S. IN BIOCHEMISTRY.
WHAT LIKE HOW SHE MET DICK DICK
FOR YEARS A CHEMISTRY STUDENT
THEY MARRIED AFTER THEY
GRADUATED AND HAD THREE
DAUGHTERS?
DONNA WAS A DEDICATED MATH AND
SCIENCE TEACHER IN THE RICHMOND
NOW WEST CONTRA COSTA SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
SHE WAS A ACTIVE MEMBER IN THE
CHILDREN WOMEN'S GOLF CLUB AN
AVID TENNIS PLAYER ON THE SAME
ALAMEDA COURTS WHERE SHE
COMPETED AS A CHILD.
AND SHE WAS ALSO A DEDICATED
BRIDGE PLAYER.
SHE WAS A BELOVED VOLUNTEER IN
THE PHYSICAL THERAPY DEPARTMENT
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL AND WROTE THE
VOLUNTEER NEWSLETTER FOR THE
WHOLE HOSPITAL AUXILIARY.
DONE ALSO SERVED AS A PRIMARY
CARE GIVER FOR MANY MEMBERS.
FAMILY MEMBERS INCLUDING HER
FATHER AND PHÃN.
HER DAUGHTER JANE AND HER
HUSBAND DICK.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
IS DAUGHTERS MARJORIE DICKINSON.
AND SALLY FOR BRING A THREE
GRAND CHILDREN MATTHEW NATALIE
TONY. TO ADORED GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN CHARLOTTE N. MATTEO AND
HER BROTHER RALPH NADER.
I RESPECTFULLY REST RIGHT
REQUEST THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF DONNA
RAE FULL YEAR.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND DAVID
MARCUS.
PROBABLY THE MOST POSITIVE
PERSON I'VE EVER MET IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
HE STARTED WORKING AT BIG IT THE
BIGGEST ARKAN DECEMBER NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE IN SHORTLY AFTER
EVERYONE SAW DAVIS POTENTIAL NEW
WAS HIRED ON AS A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE BY THE LOCAL ALBERTSONS
GROCERY STORE.
ALWAYS POSITIVE GREETING
EVERYONE WITH A SMILE.
IN ANY THAT OUTLOOK NEVER
CHANGED EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER SEVEN
TIMES HE WOULD VISIT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH
SCHOOLS WEEKLY SHARING A STORY
OF POSITIVITY.
AND PERSEVERANCE AND HE'D ALWAYS
SAY TO THEM IF I CAN DO IT YOU
CAN DO IT.
TOO AND AND THAT WAS WHAT
INSPIRED HIM AND THAT'S WHAT
INSPIRED EVERYONE AROUND HIM AND
DURING HIS VISITS ALL THE
SCHOOLS DAVID TOOK IT UPON
HIMSELF TO START DOING THUMBS UP
FOLK PHOTOS.
WITH THE STAFF AND STUDENTS
DISPLAYING IS UNWAVERING
POSITIVITY AND PASSION FOR
LIVING LIFE TO THE FULLEST.
HE WAS A FRIEND TO EVERYONE HE
MET.
I FIRST MET DAVID TEN YEARS AGO
AT LEGAL DREAMS -- EVENT AND HE
DIDN'T KNOW WHY WAS BUT HE CAME
UP TO ME AND TOLD ME I'M A SIX
TIME CANCER SURVIVOR WILL YOU
TAKE A THUMBS UP VOTER WITH ME.
AND OF COURSE I DID AND OPENED
UP A PUBLIC COUPLE HOURS LATER I
WAS TACK ON FACEBOOK AN **** AND
HE ASKED ME TO BE HIS FRIEND
INFERRED AND THAT FRIENDSHIP HAS
LASTED.
TILL TODAY.
AND DAVID THE ONLY ATTENDED A
LEGAL DREAMS ADVANCE BUT HE WAS
ACTIVE IN HONOR OF LIKE KERN
COUNTY RELAY FOR LIFE A CAMPAIGN
AGAINST CANCER HE WAS A AS
PRESIDENT AT ALL THE VETERANS
DAY PARADES AND MANY MORE.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE CURRENT
REGIONAL CENTER BOARD TO
ADVOCATE FOR ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND HE LOVED
CENTENNIAL HIGH SCHOOL.
THOUGH DAVID BATTLE WITH CANCER
THROUGH DAVID'S BATTLE WITH
CANCER HIS FAITH NEVER LEFT THEM.
HE WAS UNWAVERING AS FAITH AND
HIS LOVE FOR JESUS CHRIST AND I
KNOW THAT HE'S IN A BETTER PLACE
AND HE ALWAYS MAINTAIN THE FACT
THAT HE WANTED THE COMMUNITY. TO
BE POSITIVE AND TO BE INSPIRED
BY THE POSITIVITY AND EVEN TO
THE HIS LAST DAY.
HE HE ALWAYS WOULD WOULD
FACEBOOK ME OR TEXT ME AND TELL
ME -- TO BE POSITIVE AND SO
MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU PLEASE TO
JOIN ME IN HONORING THE MEMORY
OF MY FRIEND DAVID AND GIVING A
THUMBS UP.
ON A LIFE THAT WE SHOULD ALL
MODEL OURSELVES AFTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNAL
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING HEARING A FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED.
UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE JULY
ELEVENTH AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED